tim scott crosses the line by saying
america isn't racist
so the racist left attacks him kamala
harris touts the biden white house's
100-day record and joe biden continues
to promote useless mask theater i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from big tech with the
vpn i trust visit expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which you may have
noticed the big tech companies they
really suck like
they spend a lot of time cracking down
on speech they don't like and then they
target people they don't like and then
they use
all of your data in order to monetize
all of that well whether you're talking
about your internet service provider or
sites like google and facebook they're
monitoring what you do
at nearly all times because they're
following your ip address what is the
best way to make sure that 100 of your
data is encrypted so that you get
the power over your data back well
expressvpn would be it
expressvpn creates a secure tunnel
between all your devices and the
internet so everything you do online is
encrypted it reroutes your connection
through a secure server this blocks your
isp from seeing everything you do
online all they can see is you're
connected to an expressvpn server
nothing beyond that
it's not just for your phone or computer
expressvpn works on all your devices it
works on your tablets smart tvs even
your router so your entire family can
always stay protected i can't stress
this enough expressvpn is super
simple to use you just open up the app
you tap one button to connect that's the
whole thing
every single person should have a vpn
your data is your business protected at
expressvpn.com
get three extra months of expressvpn
protection for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
to learn more expressvpn.com ben
alrighty so senator tim scott he is the
man in the in the boot box today so
twitter is the boo box every so often
somebody just gets thrown in the blue
box from hook and then we drop scorpions
on them and they scream from inside
and then we all laugh and cheer and
senator tim scott is that man because
senator tim scott had the temerity to
say something that apparently no black
person in america is allowed to say
according to the mainstream media
which is that america is not racist see
the mainstream media have bought into
the entire racial essentialist argument
that your race is your politics
unlike religion which actually comes
along with a set of principles and so if
you say that somebody is catholic people
typically say okay well catholicism is a
set of principles if somebody says
they're catholic
probably they mirror those principles
same thing with being jewish
same thing with being protestant okay if
you say somebody is white
typically that doesn't come along with a
set of principles you must believe if
you are white but according to the left
it does if you are white you are
inherently plagued by white supremacy
and if you are black you are inherently
plagued by victimization and you have to
think
what's more that you are plagued by that
victimization if you are black
it is heresy for you to suggest that you
don't live in a viciously racist country
in which you have no agency
over your own life and tim scott makes
them irrationally angry
by saying precisely the opposite and
there's nothing new about this
the left has been extraordinarily angry
at everybody from clarence thomas to
candace owens for literally my entire
lifetime any time a black person has the
temerity to say america is not racist
i have agency i have freedom in my own
life i can make good decisions and i can
get ahead
in a free society under which equality
of rights is the law
if a black person says that the left
loses its bleep and
tim scott is just the latest example of
this so what did he say that was so bad
well
in his response to the state of the
union address that interminable
soporific
ridiculous state of the union address in
which joe biden barely
awake himself put the rest of the nation
to sleep bludgeoning us
into submission with lists of trillion
dollar spending items
and also suggested this old white man
that america is systemically racist
then tim scott got up and he said well
no america is not racist
and just because i've experienced racism
in my personal life does not mean
that america is completely racist which
is what mature adults think about the
world
just because a bad thing happened to you
does not mean the entire world is
against you
just because people have been very
anti-semitic to me does not mean that
all of america or its systems are
anti-semitic
so tim scott says this about being black
in america and this of course set off
the left
into a frenzy of apoplectic idiocy
a hundred years ago kids in classrooms
were taught the color of their skin was
their most
important characteristic and if they
looked a certain way
they were inferior today cues are being
taught
that the color of their skin defines
them again
and if they look a certain way they're
an oppressor
from colleges to corporations to our
culture people are making money
and gaining power by pretending we
haven't made any progress
at all by doubling down on the divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
it's backwards to fight discrimination
with
different types of discrimination and
it's wrong
to try to use our painful past to
dishonestly
shut down debates in the present okay of
course
every single word that tim scott says
there is exactly correct and this is
what sets off the left this is what
makes them so mad so he was subtweeting
a couple of folks there
one of the people that he was
substituting for sure was ibrahim
kennedy so when he says it is wrong to
fight discrimination with discrimination
that is a precise counter to ibrahmax
candy who has said discrimination of the
past
requires discrimination today so max
kennedy not only disagrees with tim
scott
he was basically being sub-tweeted by
tim scott right there tim scott was
saying
ever max kennedy's perverse view of
america
and the and the ramifications of abraham
ibramex kenny's views are bad for
america
tim scott saying that set off ibra max
kennedy so ibrahimovic's candy is an
absolute grifter i mean there's a guy
who's raised tens of millions of dollars
based on the lie that not only is
america racist but that is better for
america
if we treat every american by their
racially essential characteristics which
is racism
okay so tim scott tweeted out that
particular line from the speech
hear me clearly america is not a racist
country and ibrahim excandi then tweeted
back
the heartbeat of racism is denial we can
hear the heartbeat clearly
okay so april max kenzie loves to engage
i mean he's such a grifter he loves to
engage
in these kafka traps so a kafka trap is
where you accuse somebody of a crime
it comes from franz kafka's the trial
you accuse somebody of a crime and then
the person denies the crime you say well
if you really were innocent you wouldn't
be denying it would you
right so the kafka trap here is if you
say that america is not racist
this makes you a racist because you're
denying that america is racist
because only a truly non-racist person
would acknowledge
that america is in fact racist you see
how this works
okay now it makes no sense full-on
catch-22 because there is no way to get
out of that trap
it creates a completely unfalsifiable
situation it is literally the scene
from monty python and the holy grail in
which they decide that to determine
whether a witch is a witch or not
if you throw her in the water and she
and she floats
this means she's a witch and must be
burned and if you throw in the water and
she sings this means that she was not a
witch
and she's innocent but sadly she's dead
that is how anti-racism works in every
max kennedy's world
and by the way he's a racist ever
mexican is consistently saying things
about how white people are inherently
plagued with white supremacy
and mexican is consistently judging
people on the basis of the color of
their skin alone
and suggesting that america's racial
institutions are inherently racist
because
there's unequal outcome by race now as
i've said many times
you could you could take any room in
america any room full of people in
america and draw a line
along any angle in that room that
separates the population in half and you
will find
inequalities in that room you'll find
that on average one group is taller and
one group is shorter or one group is
fatter or one group is skinnier one
group has a higher iq and one group has
a lower iq or one group has more
criminals and the other has fewer
criminals
there is no line you could draw in any
room in america in which the outcome
on both sides of that line is exactly
the same on all
aspects that can be marked right that is
just not the way that statistics work
that is not the way the world works and
that's particularly true
when culture makes a difference which we
know that it does if you took a bunch of
white people from appalachia who are
living in poverty and you put them next
to a bunch of white
upper-class people living in manhattan
they're going to have
very different life outcomes and that
doesn't have anything to do with color
that doesn't mean that the system
is discriminating on the basis of
whiteness this is the point that charles
murray makes in his book coming apart he
talks about cultural differences between
white people because he said listen i
keep getting ripped on
for suggesting that culture makes a
difference in the outcome of your life
because people say that has to do with
race so i'm just going to write a book
about white people
i'm just going to write about a book
about how there are differences within
white america and how your lifestyle
makes a difference to your outcome
it doesn't matter they still call
charles murray or racist because this is
one of their favorite things to do
but you don't have to be related this is
just a religious worldview and tim scott
has attacked a religious worldview and
the left
sees him as a heretic and heretics must
be burned so it's not just about max
kennedy who is the high priest of woken
it's throughout the media it's
throughout the culture to have joy behar
lecturing tim scott about systemic
racism now
there's a word that people on left like
to use about stuff like this white
whitesplaining
joy behar explaining to tim scott about
systemic racism
is just absurd at the highest level
first of all joy behar
cannot understand basic concepts
she really has a deficiency in in
intellectually understanding things
but here she is attempting to lecture
tim scott
a black man in america who acknowledges
that he's experienced significant racism
in his life
about what systemic racism actually is
tell us joy who by the way dressed in
blackface
in costume as erica and still has her
job here she is
no tim scott he he does not seem to
understand
and a lot of them don't seem to
understand the difference between
um a racist country and
a systemic ra and systemic racism they
don't seem to get the difference yes
maybe it's not a racist country maybe
americans
the majority are not racist but we live
in a country with
systemic racism oh well it's not a
racist country
but you know it's still systemic racism
because
even though america is not racist it's
systems are racist but you can't explain
how the systems are racist because
legal racism has been illegal in the
united states
since the 1960s so as i've said before
the term systemic racism can mean a
bunch of things it can mean you're a
racist they don't say that
it can mean that every american deep
down has implicit
bias they sometimes mean that they could
say that it means legalized racism which
is not true because that's been
federally illegal since the 1960s
or they can mean that history has
consequences and because it used to be
that there was a lot of racism in the
united states that that has far-reaching
consequences
downstream which is true of all history
right it is always true that history has
impact in the here and now but the
question is how you heal that and when
you say systemic racism the idea is
there must be a quote-unquote
systemic solution well that but that's
not right
the reality is the single best way to
escape poverty is the same for every
single american
get married don't have kids until you're
married get a job
that's it if you do those things it
doesn't matter what race you are
you will succeed in america you will not
live in permanent poverty in america
statistically speaking according to the
brookings institute
but they don't want to talk about that
right because that puts personal onus on
you
and so much of the left's belief in in
what needs to happen is that you don't
have any personal responsibility the
government has to take responsibility
for everything
glenn lowry has an excellent piece over
at barry weiss's sub stack
about what systemic racism means he says
basically
systemic racism is just a mushmouth term
designed to foreclose all debate
he says the people who keep saying
systemic racism ignore the following
truth that america has basically
achieved equal opportunity in terms of
race we have chased away the jim crow
bugaboo
not just with laws but also by
widespread social customs practices and
norms
when democrats called a georgia voter
integrity law a resurgence of jim crow
it is nothing more than a lie everybody
knows there's no real jim crow to be
found anywhere in america
the phrase systemic racism does a great
disservice to blacks into the country
here we are now well into the 21st
century our lives are being remade every
decade
by technology globalization
communication innovation and yet all we
seem to hear about is race
my deep suspicion is that these charges
of systemic racism have proliferated and
grown so hysterical because black people
with full citizenship and equal
opportunity
in the most dynamic country on earth
says glenn lowry who is black are
failing to measure up
violent crime is one dimension of this
the disorder and chaos in our family
lives
is another the ironies that so many of
us describe systemic racism even as we
simultaneously demand this very same
system that deliver us it's not just
glenn lowry he's pointing this out
john mcquarter is pointing this out as
well
he says systemic racism or its
alternative term institutional racism
became common coin as a
designation in the late 1960s just as
the expression of overt personal
prejudice was increasingly proscribed
and such prejudice itself waned ever
more
leaving behind subtler kinds of bias
less easily addressed the idea behind
the phrase is that inequities between
whites and blacks on the societal level
such as in scholastic achievement wages
wealth quality of housing and health
outcomes are due to racist bias of some
kind
exercising its influence in abstract but
decisive ways
as such the existence of these
inequities represents a sort of racism
that must be battled with the same
urgency and even indignation that
personal prejudice requires
the problem is that sociology and social
history are more complex than this
interpretation of systemic racism allows
all race-based inequities are not due to
prejudice moreover
all race-based inequities do not lend
themselves to the kind of solutions that
eliminating prejudice do
for example to attribute black students
lesser performance on standardized tests
to systemic racism
is an extremely fragile proposition to
simply eliminate the test as racist
because black students underperform
is an anti-intellectual and even
destructive idea
mcquarter says i find the term systemic
racism to be the most nettlesome term in
the english language
at present it it's nettlesome because
the left constantly engages
in in in semantic overload this is their
favorite thing to do they pick a phrase
and then the phrase means ten different
things and then when you attack the most
common
use of the term they say oh no i don't
mean that right you'll say yeah systemic
racism
implies that the systems right now are
racist and they say no no that's what i
mean i mean history
you're like well okay i agree that
history has a lot of racism in it
and that there are consequences to that
but the question is how we alleviate
those consequences and they say well no
no but now you're denying that racism
exists well hold on i'm using your
definition
this is the game the game arguing with
folks on the left when it comes to terms
they have
created out of whole cloth is like
trying to nail jello to the wall
it is bound to fail because they are not
attempting to be ideologically or
intellectually consistent
all they are trying to do is trap you
the term systemic racism is a trap
because the moment you attempt to define
it they shift the definition so they can
continue to call you personally racist
right they'll say i'm not calling you a
racist i'm saying there's systemic
racism
and then you say okay define systemic
racism well if you need it to find for
you you're a racist
okay so this whole game was just to get
to the end point that you wanted to go
to in the first place which is i'm a
racist if i disagree with you
we can all see that happening and here's
the amazing thing about all of this
when it comes to who the actual races
are in american life who are the people
who are actually pushing racial
essentialism
who are the people who are suggesting
that the only reason that somebody like
tim scott would be able to get a slot
speaking opposite joe biden is because
of his race who are those people
people on the left there's a reason that
uncle tim
trended on twitter and there's a reason
that people at twitter allowed it to
trend
okay because when they were petitioned
they took it down which means they
allowed it to trend okay they allowed it
to trend because on the left it is not
considered a racist to be racist against
a black person so long as the black
person does not think like the quote
unquote
essential black person is supposed to
think we'll get to more of this in just
one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you're
a responsible citizen you need to make
sure that your family's taken care of
okay god forbid something happens to you
you need life insurance it's just the
responsible thing to do
policy genius can help you compare top
insurers in one place and save 50
or more on life insurance once you find
your best option the policy genius team
will set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
you can feel good knowing your family
has financial protection getting started
is super simple first
head on over to policygenius.com in
minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need
and compare quotes to find your best
price since their licensed agents work
for you not the insurance companies
there's no hassle
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process policy genius will
take care of everything
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews on trustpilot and
google
the best part all the benefits of policy
genius the comparison tool the handling
of paperwork the unbiased advice
are totally free to use policy genius
can promise you won't leave their
website feeling foolish
you could say 50 or more by comparing
life insurance quotes
feel good knowing if something happens
your loved ones will be taken care of go
to policygenius.com to get started right
now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice and super important
to get it right and so then we get to
the actual overt racism
of many on the left so sonny hostin also
of the view
also a a political genius says the only
reason tim scott was chosen is because
he's black
which is weird because i've been
informed by folks on the left that that
is the specific reason you should choose
people to do things
truly we've been told that you're
supposed to shop at black owned
businesses
we've been told that we needed a black
female vice president
not because of anything that she'd
accomplished in her career but because
she was black and female specifically
those were joe biden said out loud he
was looking for those characteristics in
a vice president
it's people on the left who suggest that
asian americans should essentially be
thrown out of college in favor
of black americans simply on the basis
of race but apparently now it's bad if
tim scott is chosen on the basis of his
race now the reality is that tim scott
was not just
chosen on the basis of his race he was
chosen on the basis of his viewpoints
and experience of course
which are independent of race okay tim
scott was chosen
because he was the lead in doing
criminal justice reform
on the right side of the aisle tim scott
was chosen because he does have personal
experiences
with race so he has some credibility
when he says he doesn't believe that
america
is a racist country but sunny hostin
immediately goes to
oh yeah republicans are doing this
because they're racist they picked tim
scott
a black man to deliver the response to
the state of the union address
because he's a token and they're racist
why was he chosen to give this uh
rebuttal he was chosen because he is the
only
black republican senator he is
that person he is the person that
republicans want to put out front
because
of the problem of racism in this country
and he knows that
um and and so i was sort of disappointed
that he was used
in this way and um didn't take that
opportunity to
address that type of issue this type of
issue head on
i mean it's amazing he didn't say what
sunny hostin said so it's bad that he
was picked
now i promise you that when they cast
the view race was one of the things that
they looked at right this is true
whenever you cast a show in hollywood to
pretend that race is not a factor in
casting in hollywood is just ridiculous
of course it is
of course it is they look for a
particularly diverse cast they'll say
okay we need two white women and a black
like that's how they cast these shows so
let's be real about this
people are constantly doing this in
american life the question is whether
they are doing this
because they wish to promote ideas about
race or whether they are doing this
because the person is independently
qualified and has personal experience
that can speak to the issue
that is currently being discussed which
is the story with tim scott
it is significantly less racist to
choose tim scott to do to give his state
of the union response address
talking about his experiences with race
in america than it is to choose a vice
president of the united states
specifically because you need to
apparently appease members of your
coalition
because it doesn't matter which black
person you pick it just has to be a
black person
right the republicans weren't like okay
we're just gonna pick a black person and
that black person
any elected black person would be fine
for democrats it was like okay we need a
black woman and we're gonna pick a black
woman
and here's a list of black people that
we're going
they literally did this they literally
put out a list like well it could be
karen pass or it could be val demings or
you remember this they actually went
through a selection process where they
just came up with a list
based not really on viewpoint as long as
you're on the left it was fine
it wasn't based on viewpoint it was just
based on it had to be a person
who filled this particular hole it's
but it's fine when the left does it it's
fine in fact it's praiseworthy when the
left does it you're not allowed to
oppose it when the left does it you're
not allowed to even mention it
when the left does it it's pretty
impressive stuff and the media jump in
on this as well so the washington post
issued like an all-time amazing tweet
this is an amazing amazing tweet
from the washington post quote senator
tim scott accused liberals of shutting
down debate and practicing
discrimination
republicans seized on his comments with
thursday while
activists said he was giving cover to
white supremacists
i like the washington post is just the
democratic party at this point
that they should they should gild that
that
tweet and frame it in gold and put it up
in a museum that's how good that tweet
is
senator tim scott accused liberals of
shutting down debate and practicing
discrimination
right so that's his accusation now watch
as the washington post
tries to shut down debate and practice
discrimination republicans seized on his
comments thursday they're always seizing
that's us we republican we are great at
pouncing we are great at seizing it is
our thing
activists said he was giving cover to
white supremacists well those activists
their their republicans
didn't defend tim scott they seized on
his comments but activists knew
they knew that he's actually giving
cover to white supremacists and the
washington post goes further than this
they have an entire piece titled senator
tim scott's comments on race ignite a
fiery debate
the pieces by cleve wooten and mike
debonas says republicans who have
sometimes found themselves on the
defensive in recent months when it comes
to race
praised the south carolina senator for
addressing the notion that democrats and
black activists are too quick to shout
down those who disagree with them by
calling them racist
democrats generally treated scott's
words with caution but many black
activists who publicly criticized scott
into the wee
hours thursday morning deemed him the
latest in a line of black apologists who
give political and racial cover to white
grievance
on scott on twitter scott was compared
was compared to figures like
conservative commentator candace owens
whoa
whoa i mean whoa you compared someone to
candace that means that he's bad he must
be super bad if you're comparing him to
candace
running through it all as the scott
controversy shows are competing premises
about how far the nation needs to go to
fix racial fissures and how bad the
problem still is
scott who said he had personally
experienced the pain of discrimination
said too many people suggest the country
has gained no ground when it comes to
civil rights
republicans seized on the notion that
democrats are only too happy to
criticize
america but the activists
the activists they they're fighting back
because apparently he's he's providing
cover
to white supremacists i i think that the
the very very white washington post
should talk about this
jeff bezos needs to sound off on this
pretty impressive stuff by the way
this is the pattern here the pattern is
the left says ridiculous things about
race and if you respond
you are the instigator give you a
perfect example in one second
okay so it turns out the biden
administration is now attempting to
basically push
critical race theory which is this idea
that all of america's institutions are
shot through with racism that america is
rooted in racism
and that all those institutions need to
be torn down the body administration is
trying to cram that into america's
education system
so the education department has now made
clear that it wishes to teach ibram x
candystyle grifter bullcrap
so they put out for example a list of
the resources they are recommending that
schools use included in that list
is the 1619 project which is a piece of
ridiculous fiction i've gone through it
in significant detail in my book how to
destroy america in three
easy steps i've also talked about it at
length on the show you can go back and
look at the old episodes
not only is it rooted in bad history i
mean called out by a variety
of historians from every political
viewpoint basically i mean for example
the original 1619 project suggested that
it was the alternative history of
america the true history of america and
then nicole hannah jones
who is a ridiculous person immediately
walked that back when she got hit by oh
i didn't mean it was the actual history
of america i suggested
that it should be read you know as sort
of a counter and an account or part to
the traditional history of america
that's not what she originally suggested
she originally suggested in her
opening essay for the 1619 project that
the
s that the revolutionary war was fought
in order to preserve slavery there's no
evidence of this it's just not true
actually it's just outright untrue okay
so it's a bad piece
of of non-journalism and non-history
and the education department under joe
biden wants all american school children
presumably
to learn about it and the republicans
say no they're probably going to say no
we're going to defund this we don't like
this
how is that treated it's treated by
politico today as though the republicans
are being aggressive
anything democrats do is the default
anything republicans do to stop that
is aggressive republicans are always the
instigators so you'll see democrats say
things like men are women and women are
men and republicans like nope hold up a
second we're going to stop you right
there
and the media treat republicans get
aggressive on culture war issues like
hold up here i was just sitting here
i was sitting there doing nothing and
then you told me that boys can be girls
and i was like no and you're like oh
well that's your fault how dare you be
so aggressive
it's like you slap america in the face
and then america says i don't like that
like you bastard you will like it
right that that's what they're doing now
right you're we're going to cram down on
your school kids the idea that america
is systemically racist that our true
founding is not 1776 but 16 19
and then we say no and then you're like
how dare you
you aggressive jerk how dare you start
this culture where i didn't start the
culture where i was just freaking
sitting here
you keep changing the root standard of
how we educate our children
basic logic and science and then when we
say no
you call us an aggressor okay here's a
perfect example so here's politico
on mitch mcconnell saying he doesn't
like the 6019 project being funded
by the education department okay here's
the here's the piece
mcconnell takes on the 1619 project this
is from the playbook the vaunted
playbook which by the way
i wrote once and hundreds of political
staffers called in to complain how did i
i touched the vaunted political playbook
you remember this just a couple months
ago exclusive mcconnell leans into the
culture wars
he says mcconnell started a culture war
you see it wasn't
that a bunch of aggressive leftists
decided to rewrite american history
and put in its place a pseudo-history in
which america is a great villain
no it's that mcconnell's getting
aggressive senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell and 37 gop senators will call
on the education department today
to stop a proposed rule that invokes the
1619 project the latest turn in the
culture wars
the biden administration citing the
ongoing reckoning over race and the
disproportionate effects of the pandemic
on african americans has proposed
updating american history curricula to
more fully flesh out the consequences of
slavery and contributions of black
americans now you gotta love how
politico covers this
right so in other words your kid in
public school has to learn
that america was rooted in slavery
because of the quote unquote ongoing
reckoning over race okay that's
completely circular so you make a case
i say no that's an ongoing reckoning
over race so you lose
okay also it's amazing how they just
repeat the same
phraseology i mean it's like it's like
down to
down to the propagandistic semantics
reckoning it's
always a reckoning reckoning reckoning
reckoning okay
it seems like if we're gonna have a
reckoning it kind of happened mostly in
the 60s
right when we completely reshifted the
nature of american law in many good ways
okay and the disproportionate effects of
the pandemic on african americans
question
what does that have to do with the 1619
project seriously what's the
disproportionate effect
of the pandemic on african-americans
have to do with the 6019 project
and also why is it that you are you're
divvying this thing up by race as
opposed to by class
cova disproportionately affected
low-income people
covet does not affect black people worse
than it affects everybody else covet is
not racist
cause it's a horrible virus it's not
racist
and the the basic notion now that
everybody can get a vaccine that the
the the vaccination process must be
disproportionately targeting
non-black americans is also a lie what
you're seeing is extreme
vaccine hesitancy centralized in large
parts of
black america and the media covering for
it by the way how many articles have you
seen about how it's
tuskegee all over again and people are
worried about tuskegee all over again
it's like well
no that is not a good reason not to get
a covered vaccine in any case
politico says the lightning rod for
republicans that the proposal
specifically mentions the 1619 project
which several
prominent historians have criticized in
a letter mcconnell and other senators
will blast the administration for
putting ill-informed advocacy ahead
of historical accuracy the missive comes
as former president donald trump on
thursday called for mcconnell to be
replaced as leader
also it must be that he's pressured into
this is what they're saying now i i do
love
that political late in this piece notes
that a bunch of people who are not
conservative also oppose the 16-19
project which of course is true
but the idea here is that republicans
are always the aggressors in the culture
war
democrats get aggressive republicans
respond and it's all about how
republicans are the true aggressors here
now what's amazing about all of this
is that kamala harris can say the same
exact thing as tim scott about america
not being racist
and not receive the same flag because of
course everybody knows that she wants to
tear down america's institutions
so long as you want to tear down
america's institutions you can say
whatever the hell you want here's kamala
harris
saying also that america's not racist
but but
america's kinda racist i don't think
america is a racist country but we also
do have to speak truth about the history
of racism in our country and it's
and its existence today and i i applaud
the president
for always having the ability and the
courage frankly
to speak the truth about it let's deal
with it
knowing we all have so much more in
common than what separates us
um so i noticed that um this is the same
president who she's praising right now
is the same one she was calling a
vicious racist who wouldn't let little
girls like her go to school
like a year and a half ago so color me a
little bit skeptical
that there's any level of principle
involved here this is all just political
cynicism
as always as always okay in just a
second we're gonna get to kamala harris
touting
the biden administration's 100-day
record which of course is built on
a barrage of lies we'll get to that in
just one second first
let's talk about the fact that if you
are a responsible parent for example
if you're a husband or a wife if you
just want to keep an eye on your
property you want to make sure that you
know what's going on at your house
and this is why we have ring devices on
our house and when we moved from
california to florida my wife said
listen i don't feel safe in the house
until we have ring devices on the house
i want to be able to see the kids i want
to be able to see
what's going on on our doorstep even if
we're not home that's what ring does
for us and that's what i can do for you
as well now is the perfect time to
upgrade your doorstep with a ring
video doorbell with ring you can keep an
eye on your home no matter where you are
directly from your phone
ring has hassle free easy to install
indoor and outdoor cams so you'll never
miss a visitor you can keep those
packages and delivery safe
with motion detection you'll get
notified even if they don't ring the
doorbell
if somebody stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know which is
awesome there's a special offer
on the ring welcome kit right now at
ringgit.com it comes with rings video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro
don't wait get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit at ring.com
ben right now it comes that ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro it's the
perfect way to start your ring
experience go to ring.com
once more that is ring.com ben to get
started
all right we're gonna get to more in
just one second including
policy blowback there's going to be
blowback to what joe biden is attempting
right now
first as you all know the daily wire has
been growing like mad not only did we
move the whole company across the
country we also released our first
feature film we struck up a movie deal
with gina carano and launched a brand
new talk show hosted by candace owens
all within the last six months okay
there's an amazing amount of change
right we're over here in florida a great
red state our
company is based in nashville a great
red state and we are growing by leaps
and bounds we have big plans for what we
want to do
next we've been moving at the speed of
light over here i'm excited for the
future of the company so excited all of
us here at dailywear want to express our
gratitude to you
our audience for making all of this
possible and we want to include you
in our future plans every day on the
show i talk about a lot of amazing
products and services from the sponsors
that i love
and use but we also want to get to know
you better so we can choose our sponsors
with you in mind so that we can
get you access to the products that you
like the best and so we can present
those products to you so please
go to dailywire.com shapiro fill out my
audience survey tell us a little bit
more about yourself to sweeten the whole
experience
those of you that complete the survey
will be entered to win a one thousand
dollar gift card you can only take that
survey once
per daily wire show so if you want to
increase your chances of winning a
thousand bucks go listen to michael
moles and cleveland or mount walsh to
get access to their surveys
as well again my survey link is
dailywire.com
shapiro we would definitely love to hear
from you also
i am seriously looking forward to this
upcoming sunday special where i'll be
hosting my good friend jordan peterson
our favorite clinical psychologist and
the author of beyond order 12 more rules
for life jordan is a
profound thinker and a really
considerate human being
and obviously the left hates his guts
and we talk a lot about that here's a
little sneak peek of what we talked
about you're gonna love it
there's a group of people who by your
own admission are disaffected
and angry and alienated and young
and i'm helping them and why is that
exactly a problem
what is it that i'm supposed to be doing
with them just out of curiosity what do
you think
if you had your druthers would i ignore
them
it's a great sunday special you're gonna
love it go check it out this sunday at
dailywire.com or on my youtube channel
ben shapiro daleyware members get access
to special bonus content from sunday's
special episodes so don't miss out
join daily wire today also get ready to
stream the latest episode of candace
tonight she sits down with dave rubin
political commentator best-selling
author host of the reuben report they'll
be discussing everything from caitlyn
jenner's gubernatorial runs the recall
of gavin newsom it's definitely an
episode you won't want to miss also i'm
on the panel so if you love me you will
love this episode of candace also catch
for wednesday next week for an interview
with a very special guest so subscribe
now
stream candace live on fridays 9 pm
eastern 8 pm central only
on dailywear get 25 off a new membership
with code candace
at dailywire.com subscribe also make
sure you grab the audio on apple
spotify wherever your platform of choice
may be just head to apple podcast or
spotify subscribe to candas today
please leave us a five star review
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
alrighty so meanwhile kamala harris gave
an address yesterday
in which she talked about what a
wonderful job they've done over the
first 100 days
now let's be real about this they really
have not done anything except for pass a
bunch of spending that's it and that
spending is super heating
the economy right now overheating the
economy we're seeing massive inflation
in things like lumber the price of
lumber is up like over 100
we're seeing commodities prices
skyrocket because it turns out that
there's a shortage of commodities
and people can't go back to work there's
still a bunch of places where you're not
allowed to go back to work and not only
that
even in places where you can go back to
work the government has basically paid
you to stay home
small business owners all over the
country and big business owners actually
are telling me they're having trouble
finding employees to come back to work
because the government has paid them so
much money to not go back to work
it's truly incredible but according to
kamala harris they're doing just a
stellar job here's kamal o'hara
celebrating kamala harris because that
lady loves her some kamala harris
in 100 days we have created more new
jobs
than any other administration in history
we have two more plans that we are
working to get past
the first is the american jobs plan it
will be the largest
job investment that our nation has made
since world war ii because the fact is
too many people including too many
people right here in maryland are still
out of work so while we have made
significant process
progress on the jobs front there's so
much more to be done
um so i i just have a question what did
she do to generate 1.3 million new jobs
the answer of course is nothing those
jobs were being created
they were being created because the
pandemic is ending but again this is the
entire shtick of the biden
administration jump in front of a moving
parade and then lead it down a dead end
like animal house
that's exactly what this is and then
starts piling up behind them
right everybody's cheering right now but
as soon as they turn into that dead end
things are going to get really ugly but
don't worry
they're going to move faster into that
wall here's kamala harris saying we need
gun laws we need racial justice
legislation we need all the things
everything let's just do it man go for
it balls to the wall let's do this thing
there have been too many days when we
woke up
to news of another mass shooting
another black or brown person shot by
the police
another act of hate against asian
americans
another law designed to make it harder
for people to vote
these are reminders that we still have
so much more work
to do in the fight for reasonable gun
laws
in the fight for racial justice the
fight for voting rights
more stuff all the stuff do more stuff
meanwhile the u.s labor secretary
has now suggested that california's
brilliant idea to classify
gig workers as employees effectively
attempting to kill uber and lyft and
then they had to create a carve out for
uber and lyft so they can continue to
operate
they want to now extend that nationwide
which is such a genius idea
the labor secretary marty walsh says
quote we are looking at it but in a lot
of cases gig workers should be
classified
as employees in some cases they are
treated respectfully in some cases they
are not i think it has to be consistent
across the board these companies are
making profits and revenue
we want to make sure success trickles
down to the worker okay maybe the reason
that they are making profits in revenue
is because they have engaged in
voluntary transactions with gig workers
who will lose their jobs if you do this
which is exactly what happened
in california so here's the thing
democrats who are actually in the
business of legislating
democrats particularly in purple states
are beginning to look cross-eyed at what
exactly the biden administration has
planned so the ones in blue states are
like yeah man let's go for it
like chris coons in delaware he's like
he doesn't care right he's
he's solid in his seat he's like we
can't leave policies on the table let's
just go for it you know you have the
opportunity
once in a lifetime man but yolo here's
chris coons
i think the president has done a great
job of putting forward proposals
suggestions for how we pay for um
all of his uh major plans the rescue
plan the jobs plan the family
plan he's put forward ways to pay for
them and turn to us and said you're the
senate
do your job as he said last night roll
up your sleeves get to work
um i think we need to pay for as much of
it as we reasonably can
but we shouldn't leave bold proposals on
the table simply because we can't come
to an agreement on pay force i love this
i love this he's like we can't leave
bold proposals on the table just because
we have no idea how we're going to pay
for things
this is just the excuse that pretty much
every spendaholic has
everybody who's ever destroyed their
life through credit card debt has
exactly this excuse
every single person like you know what
listen i understand that i don't have
any money
and i really don't know how to pay for
this but that is a sweet
deal on that car right there that is an
amazing deal and if i leave that deal on
the table i'm just not gonna be able to
live with myself
so chris coon's like this is an amazing
deal on spending you know 10 trillion
dollars
and just because we have no idea how to
pay for it i mean we'll figure it out
because
life has a way life finds way but you
know we don't really need to think about
that right now but just because we can't
agree on you know
like how we actually pay for these
things that doesn't mean that we can't
just do it anyway and meanwhile he's in
a blue state
so who cares what he thinks it's the
democrats in purple states who are the
indicator that they know they are going
too far
like way too far too fast so joe manchin
was asked about the
state of the union address the jo the
fake state of the union that joe biden
gave
the worst fake it was the worst address
to a joint session of congress i've ever
seen
he was asleep the audience was asleep
there were seven people in there they
were all masked for no reason
so joe manchin was asked about this
litany of spending that joe biden wants
to do
and manchin who's from a red state is
like um no
just no on that when you look at the
overall price tag of all these proposals
that's a lot i mean we're looking for
millions and trillions of dollars here's
the thing
we've got 1.9 trading that hasn't gone
out the door yet we just passed
american rescue today it needs to be
fully paid for we need to pay for it we
do i mean we're 28.5
almost 28.2 and a half trillion dollars
now that's not sustainable and anybody's
book is not sustainable
i mean it's just amazing okay so manchin
who's you know the swing mode
he's like nah nah is a lot of money that
you're spending meanwhile you got mark
kelly
who's also in a purple state and he put
out a statement after the
state of the union address said well i
shared president biden's urgency in
fixing
our broken immigration system what i
didn't hear tonight was a plan to
address it
i'll continue holding this
administration accountable to deliver
the resources and staffing necessary for
humane
orderly processes work to improve border
security support local economies and fix
our immigration system so kelly just
wants to retain a seat he's up for
re-election in a couple years
and uh and kelly's thinking to himself
um this guy is going to lose my seat you
want to talk about republicans pouncing
here's where republicans start to pounce
because mitch mcconnell is like
basically biden is bernie joe biden is
just giving republicans talking points
with which to run
here's mcconnell making that point he's
not trying to do anything remotely close
to moderate think of it as the biden
bait and switch
he ran as a moderate but everything he's
recommended so far has been
hard left bernie sanders is really happy
he may have lost the nomination but he
won the argument
over what today's democratic party is
more taxes more spending more borrowing
and he's of course exactly right about
this
and the new york times was basically
doubling down on this you remember the
headlines
right after the the speech by biden
all the headlines were how he was going
to radically transform the nature of
american government
how he was going to change everything
about america the headlines from the
washington post
biden pitches ambitious investments tax
plans as he recasts the role of
government
okay recast the role of government watch
for that to be a phrase
that is used in every republican ad in
2022 the new york times
biden makes case to vastly expand
government's world now this is a
positive them right they're very excited
about this but
that's only the new york times
readership everybody else in the country
sees
vastly expand government's role they're
like um what now
i mean like all of the headlines are
actually bad for biden and people in the
purple states know it it's why you've
seen val demings backing off
in florida of the ridiculous anti-police
position taken by the democratic party
in the makia bryan shooting
it's why you have seen stacey abrams in
georgia going yeah this whole boycott
georgia thing not super into it even
though i kind of endorsed it
she went back and she wrote her own usa
today op-ed to get rid of all the
lines that basically made excuses for
boycotting and of course usa today went
and self-edited on her behalf
because this is what our establishment
media institutions do
so in the purple states democrats are
starting to run scared they should be
running scared
they should be because what biden is
doing right now is going to have
tremendously negative ramifications for
the american economy
most americans are not in favor of this
sort of radical change they don't like
it
joe biden doesn't care because he ain't
going gonna be around to see the
ramifications
so what does he care but you know who
does care all those people
in the purple states all of those
democrats in the purple states they're
beginning to be like i don't know
about this meanwhile joe biden is not
stopping i mean can't stop won't stop
pop star never stopped never stopping
joe biden yesterday
he did an event an outdoor event and at
this
outdoor event aside from having weird
face masking issues which we'll get to
in a second
he had this odd exchange where people
were yelling at him there were a bunch
of anti-ice protesters who showed up and
they started shouting at him abolish
ice close the detention centers and
biden either not hearing them
or hearing them either way it's not
great immediately is like i want to do
what you guys want
listen to this is crazy
i agree with you i'm working on a man
give me another five days
and everybody cheers okay they're
chanting they're chanting abolish
ice close all the detention centers he's
like i'm working on it man
give me another five double dare dreams
there's a moderate moderate
and don't don't give me the he's not a
radical when he's literally saying
i agree with you two people shouting at
him abolish ice and close all the
detention centers
meanwhile what the hell's happening on
the border nothing good border state
sheriff mark daniels said yesterday but
i didn't care what happens here which is
obviously true
we hear the people's voices we're gonna
do our job
they didn't hear what they needed to
hear last night from the president we
had
we expected to hear more we didn't get
that from him and that shows you
this presidency doesn't care about
what's happening here but the sheriff's
do and we're going to continue to stand
up for
the people and for america okay and
by the way how bad is the situation on
the border so in the middle
of an interview a live interview with a
texas rancher
on the border in the middle of this live
interview with dana perrino
this texas rancher his name is john
sewell he was interrupted
because the border patrol was chasing
illegal immigrants across his property
like the background okay this is just a
mel brooks comedy at this point
here here is the here is the fox news
interview that went viral yesterday
dana i'm sorry i had a group of guys
coming through looking for some
immigrants
um you're going to have to put it back
at me again
i'm just going to tell you go ahead we
i'm just going to tell you that we don't
have
you know we're not getting the the
support as the u.s
this is not fanning out good for us
we're under siege here
and when i say that i i've already
caught three this morning
before breakfast you know he's talking
about illegal immigrants crossing his
property but i didn't give a crap about
that
because for biden it's all about what
can i do that's radical right now
and you know he's gonna be one-term
president he knows he's gonna be one
from presidency get it all done
right now and what he's going to do also
in order to get it all done right now is
prolong the feeling of panic
so biden continues to promote ridiculous
ideas about face masking
his own cdc says you don't have to mask
when you're outdoors right the cdc is
way too cautious by the way
i mean that's not me saying that that's
the washington post saying that
the health 202 by paige cunningham today
cdc's mask guidance is still too strict
for the vaccinated some experts say
okay but even the cdc's two strict
standards say that if you're vaccinated
you don't have to wear a mask outside
uh so here is joe biden literally
yesterday
literally yesterday masking outside and
then when he takes off his mask and he
can't find it again
then he's like oh they're gonna put me
in trouble i probably but no more
matlock for me
he says you're about to region here he
is
where's my mouse can't find it
you're vaccinated i love the music in
the background it's really i can't find
my mouse let's go oh god
you're vaccinated outside looking for my
mask i'm in trouble
i'm in trouble and where's my mask i
don't know what's going on
you don't need it you're outside you're
vaccinated
the hell but again the the whole goal
here is to make it feel as though the
pandemic is never over it's the never
ending
pandemic it's not just me saying this
it's not a right left thing there's a
science thing here's cnn's medical
analyst saying joe biden is consistently
sending the wrong message about this
stuff
right this is the the cnn medical
analyst this is leanna wen
she says with masks and distancing
biden's speech sent the wrong message
about the power of our vaccines yeah no
bleep
someone's been saying this and by the
way there have been people attempting to
ban us for saying that
for a while here but this is the game
the game is you pretend
that this is still a crisis you can ram
through all of this stuff fine do it
fine seriously do it we'll see how it
works out for you it's a bold move
cotton we'll see how it works out for
you in the 2022 election cycle
alrighty we will be back here later
today with an additional hour of the ben
shapiro show first
don't forget to end it your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you
so head on over to dailywire.com this
evening 7 pm eastern tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin